روسيا من دون بوتين مشهد ربما يصعب على
الكثيرين تخيله سؤالا طرحته مجله تايم
الامريكيه ماذا لو اختفى الرئيس الروسي
الحالي فلاديمير بوتين من المشهد ماذا لو
تنح او ستيل او فارق الحياه الامريكيون
ربما ياملون بان توطد روسي علاقتها مع دول
الغرب بعد حقبه بوتين لكن لمجله تايم راي
اخر فهي تستبعد هذا السيناريو وتعزو السبب
الى ان قوه روسيا تنبع من اجهزتها الامنيه
والاستخباراتيه وهو الشيء الوحيد الذي لم
يتغير منذ زمن الاتحاد السوفيتي
والانقلابات وثورات التي تلت تلك الفتره
فالمجله وصفت تلك الاجهزه بصامحه الملوك
واشارت الى ان اخر تقديرات في عام 2019
اظهرت ان 77% من الحكومه هم اشخاص يتبعون
ما سمتها
عن المشهد السياسي في روسيا فان
الاحتماليه الاكبر ان خليفته سيستمر
باتباع النهج ذاته في الحكم وبالتالي نصحت
المجله دول الغرب بتقبل حقيقه ان الصراع
والتنافسيه الروسيين مع الغرب هما نهد
روسيا كدوله وليس نهج بوتان وحده